Daniel, I think that Instagram and Twitter
are tremendously different. I think Twitter
is kind of the townhall, the cocktail party
of our society. When things happen in the
world, you know that is where we are going,
you know unfortunate hostage situation in
Sydney. I am not running to Insta to see the
pictures. I am running to Twitter for the
conversation on the flip side. I do not believe
there is a social network in the world that
exists right now that has more of the end
attention of the consumer than Instagram meaning
looking at those pictures pretty carefully.
In this world by comparison, you know, it
is, you know this episode is going to tie
nice together because, nicely, I know the
other questions and I know my push for Insta.
I think it is about attention on the gram
and I think that is where it is really winning.
I think people are really consuming content
and paying attention, one of the reasons that
Twitter is evolving is you know I used to
able to send a tweet six years ago and even
though with substantial less of an audience
of reach, I had more action because the attention
was more serious. Now, the fire hose has gotten
so intense, so those are the variables, you
know. From a net-net game of attention,
I think it is pretty close but Instagram is
clearly going in the right direction. They
just both act differently. That is all.